[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily a
strict ruling from the judge admits
verdict watch in the kyle rin house
trial i have instructed that no one from
msnbc
news will be permitted in this building
for the duration of this trial
and the death of a mod arbory trial i
just killed a man i had blood on me
still i was the most dramatic event of
my life defendant travels me michael is
back on the stand for intense
cross-examination plus an exoneration
decades in the making two men are now
cleared in the assassination of civil
rights leader malcolm x high profile
attorney gloria allred takes on the
deadly rush shooting accusing actor alec
baldwin of playing russian roulette on
the set long crime daily covering court
cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin thursday marked day three of
verdict watch in the contentious case of
kyle rainhouse as the jury continued
deliberation the judge banned a media
organization from the courthouse after
an accusation that a reporter followed a
bus carrying jurors our angel olivia is
live outside the kenosha county house
and jeanette what can you tell us about
the judge's ruling
brian this is a big deal word spread
quickly throughout the courthouse here
on day three of deliberations that
someone in the media was being accused
of following jurors judge bruce
schroeder called both the prosecution
and the defense and kyle rittenhouse
into the courtroom and explained that he
was banning msnbc from the courthouse
after police stopped a man on wednesday
working for them who was following the
bus carrying jurors
[Music]
a person who identified himself as james
j morrison
and who claimed that he was a producer
with nbc news
employed
for msnbc under the supervision of
someone named irene bion in new york
for msnbc
the police when they stopped him because
he was following in a distance of about
a block and uh went through a red light
pulled him over and inquired of him what
was going on and he
gave that
information and stated that he had been
instructed by ms bion
in new york to
follow the jury bus
i have instructed that no one from msnbc
news will be permitted in this building
for the duration of this trial
this is a very serious matter and i
don't know what the ultimate truth of it
is
but absolutely
it would go without
much
thinking that someone who is following a
jury bus
that is a very ex that's extremely
serious matter
i contacted nbc news and a spokesperson
sent the following statement it reads
last night and that was wednesday night
a freelancer received a traffic citation
while the traffic violation took place
near the jury van the freelancer never
contacted or intended to contact the
jurors during deliberations and never
photographed or intended to photograph
them we regret the incident and will
fully cooperate with the authorities on
any investigation and that investigation
is underway and ongoing according to
kenosha police and judge schroeder now
meanwhile as you can probably hear there
are still protesters and supporters of
kyle rittenhouse who have gathered here
outside the courthouse as the jury
continues to deliberate
they chased him and
he did not essentially came here to kill
nobody he was actually standing to
protect the neighborhood that was his
purpose i i hung with a lot of people
that stood there with rifles just to
protect the neighborhood we have the
right to bear arms i'm a
constitutionalist he's a
constitutionalist he's a vigilante
um
we don't think vigilantes have have the
right to self-defense um he killed uh
anti-racist protesters
who were out protesting against police
terrorism
now things have actually been peaceful
during day three of deliberations here
at the courthouse following a fight here
on wednesday someone threw a punch on
the courthouse steps hitting a
photographer then things moved into the
street where kenosha county sheriff's
deputies and police officers took two
people into custody a man and a woman
were loaded into a police van both face
charges including disorderly conduct now
today among all of the yelling from
supporters of kyle rittenhouse and
protesters there was actually a pretty
nice moment thanks to kenosha county
sheriff
take a look at this sheriff dave beth
brought cookies and coffee outside and
set up tables at the courthouse and
everybody was welcome to have a cup of
coffee and a cookie he called them
cookies for peace protesters and even
kyle rittenhouse supporters ate some of
the cookies had some coffee
sheriff beth talked with us about why he
bought the cookies
about five years ago we had
we had another protest in front of the
safety building and brought out carrot
cakes to everybody
and it was amazing how
it kind of helped everybody down and i
hope the goal is to show everybody we're
on the same page to
be voice our opinion or
what we're here together and we're here
to do it
and who doesn't like cookies and coffee
it brought people together
at least for a couple of minutes and
sheriff beth said he does not expect a
lot of trouble here following a verdict
if a verdict is reached he said that's
according to the intelligence reports
he's receiving brian
thanks antoinette joining us now is
co-host terry austin and criminal
defense attorney taylor coss taylor as
the hours of deliberation continue what
do you think is giving the jury pause in
coming to a verdict
so you know brian thanks for having me
by the way um you know look they're into
it now as you know they're deliberating
for well over 22 hours and and what's
happening you know trying first trying
to interpret what the jury's doing is
like reading tea leaves that you know
it's one thing that attorneys always try
to do and it's really hard to put a
finger on it but when they're so deep
into it now 20 plus hours in
one might think that it's starting to
become a little bit more about the
jurors personalities and maybe less
about the evidence so what i mean by
this is after 20 25 hours of
deliberations people have are you know
firm in their beliefs they have divided
into teams in the jury you know we don't
know the sides we don't know the numbers
but there are people that are in support
of a guilty verdict and there are people
who are against it and really it comes
down to a battle of attrition now who is
firmer in their beliefs and who's
willing to play the long game all right
we'll see how that goes terry judge
schrader has already expressed his
concern about the media after this
incident with msnbc do you think he will
exclude the media in future trials
you know he might just do that brian he
was very concerned with what happened
with this msnbc reporter he said it was
very serious and now in addition to his
concerns about fairness to the
defendants his concerns about the
fairness to the parties he was concerned
about criticism about how he was running
the courtroom in addition to all that
now he has to be concerned about the
safety and the anonymity of those jurors
and he was right to make the statement
that he made and he was right to say
he's going to take this up to the
highest level so i think a good decision
on his part
now angenette what was the reaction of
the media both inside and outside the
courtroom after hearing msnbc was
excluded from the court
well when this first you know word about
this first started spreading we know
that the media coordinator was with a
deputy and the judge said find msnbc and
nbc and so we all thought oh my goodness
we hope something really awful didn't
happen where everybody is kind of tossed
out of here at least the cameras if he
was going to exclude the media he would
have to hold some type of hearing on
that and the media would be able to
argue against it but
once we found out what had happened i
don't think anybody was surprised judge
schroeder
is open to the media being in the
courtroom but we've been told if you
break the rules you're out makes sense
and probably a good ruling based on how
that information came about about that
reporter following that group of jurors
thank you everyone still ahead on law
and crime daily decades after a wrongful
conviction two men are exonerated in the
assassination of malcolm x
but first for back to back days
defendant traffic michael takes the
stand in the death of ahmad arboree
trial plus a defense motion to admonish
the prosecution all that and more after
this
[Music]
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
the three men charge will now stand
trial for live galvado gambo coverage of
the trial subscribe to law and crime on
youtube tv today
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
defendants rest their cases in the death
of a mod arbory trial out of glenn
county georgia
mcmichael and fought his father gregory
mcmichael along with neighbor william
roddy bryan are on trial in the death of
25 year old aubry all three men face
life in prison if convicted on charges
of malice murder felony murder and
aggravated assault aubry's death
captured the nation's attention after a
video of the february 2020 shooting went
viral gregory and travis mcmichael
tailed aubry in a pickup truck as he
went for a run near his home he was
unarmed at the time trouser michael
eventually shot and killed him claiming
self-defense and citizens arrest that
has since been repealed and replaced
brian recorded the entire incident on
video on thursday cross-examination
continued for trouse mcmichael who
testified he believes aubrey was a
threat even though he did not pull out a
weapon
hasn't said anything to you he knew he
has not said anything yet remember he
hasn't verbally threatened you
verbally no
still running with his hands at his
sides directly towards me yes ma'am
hasn't pulled out a gun uh hasn't seen a
gun with a weapon yet no
and hasn't hasn't shown you a weapon
this entire time he has not
hasn't said a word the entire time not
one time
all he's done is run away from you
run past me yes ma'am
and you pulled out a shotgun and pointed
it at him
running directly towards me
and this is now the second time on the
road coming directly and then watching
how he interacted with the pickup truck
uh in that general location when i
pulled the first time attacking the
truck and then seeing him
interact with the vehicle
on
burford
saying that the police are coming i'm
turning and running
on top of seeing mr al benzi pointing
and the whole february 11th episode
i was under the depression and i was
at this point this guy can be a threat
and he is coming directly to me
following cross-examination defense
attorney laura hogue called for the
admonishment of prosecutor larissa
oliveira after she asked witness lindy
cough coffer quote do you believe that
someone stealing is deserving of the
death penalty following hogue's motion
defense attorney kevin gough called for
a mistrial
it's inappropriate it's incendiary it's
prejudicial
it's improper and we ask that she be
sanctioned in front of the jury for
having done that in such a in any case
but in such a serious case
we join now
your honor i'd join in that motion and
if i can have the lunch recess to confer
with council
without waiving the issue i don't
understand why we're not moving for why
there wasn't a motion for a mistrial i
don't know how you cure that
but given that all the time that we've
put into this trial and i'm talking
about
everybody in the judicial system
before making that motion the court will
allow me i'd like to have the lunch
break to confer
maybe there's something i'm missing here
that's not not the appropriate thing to
ask for but if i have to do it now or
lose it then i'm going to move for a
mistrial
let's bring back criminal defense
attorney taylor coss and terry austin
taylor we've heard long reports that
travis mcmichael called aubry a racial
slur after the shooting but the
prosecution didn't get it in before
resting what happened there
yeah i'm quite frankly i'm surprised
that that this testimony was not let in
especially when the individual who
allegedly said it is on the witness
stand uh you know this goes directly to
intent what's the frame of what's the
frame of mind of this individual if he's
using a racial slur does this really fit
into the alleged defense of self-defense
so i'm quite frankly stunned i
understand the concept that you know you
can't if you ask the question and he
says no i did not say that you're kind
of stuck with the answer but i still
don't understand why he's prevented from
asking a question i think the jury
should be able to hear this and evaluate
the credibility of that statement it
goes directly to intent it goes directly
to the core of the defense and i'm quite
frankly stunned that it was uh not
allowed in you know it was interesting
how that's being decided and wasn't
really ruled on before they arrested
terry after a motion by the defense
judge romsey ruled uh to admonish the
prosecutor for a controversial question
about the death penalty do you think
that was the right call
oh it definitely was the right call in
fact i was very surprised to hear
larissa oliveira say that question it
was just a witness who was a neighbor
and she asked have you ever been the
subject of a crime and then the very
next question was do you think someone
stealing should get the death penalty it
was offensive and i think laura hogue
made the right motion i don't think it
should have been a motion as we know
already that kevin goff did for a
mistrial the judge did the right thing
he said it was not necessary it was
irrelevant and so you know he admonished
her in front of the jury and that was
the right solution yeah but interesting
to see how the jury interprets that
admonishing of a prosecutor in front of
them agreed not the right place or the
question to ask
coming up on law and crime daily alec
baldwin slammed with another lawsuit
stemming from the deadly shooting on the
set of his latest movie plus an
exoneration of decades in the making how
a two-year-long investigation cleared
the men convicted for the assassination
of malcolm x
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily two
men convicted for the assassination of
famed civil rights leader malcolm x are
exonerated for the crime more than half
a century later
muhammad aziz and khalil islam were
convicted in the 1965 shooting death of
malcolm x at the time of the
assassination malcolm x was delivering a
speech in new york city his pregnant
wife and daughters were in attendance a
year later aziz and islam were sentenced
to life in prison along with muhammad
jahid abdul
confessed to the murder during the trial
and admitted neither aziz or islam were
part of the scheme both men always
maintained their innocence aziz now 83
years old was released from prison in
1985. islam was released in 1987. he
died in 2009 after at the age of 74.
after a two years long reinvestigation
into the case both men were exonerated
for the crime on thursday
here to discuss this exoneration in
decades in the making is criminal
defense attorney taylor cost and co-host
terry austin taylor as a former brooklyn
d.a who ran the conviction integrity
unit what are your thoughts on an
exoneration after a two-year long
investigation
yeah so that you know the first thing
that comes to mind is that it's good to
know to be reinforced the concept that
justice does not have time limits that
no matter what that as long as there are
people good people working in conviction
review units conviction integrity units
at different prosecutors offices across
the country that things like this can
happen and the good thing about these
types of investigations are that the
prosecutors work in tandem with the
attorneys for the alleged wrongfully
confused that wrongfully convicted and
that way there's a give and take there's
a sharing of evidence and this is how
justice happens you know there's not one
side withholding from the other trying
to get an edge up when you're working
together and really your only goal is
the truth great things like this can
happen and so it's a great day exactly
now terry does this exoneration and the
reasons for it create a civil claim for
aziz or islam's estate against the state
or fbi
you know what brian you are reading my
mind a wrongfully convicted individual
has two options they can sue under the
state's exoneration statute but there's
a limit there it's kept the number of
years multiplied by a certain amount of
money but they can also sue under the
constitution basically if they were
deprived of some sort of due process and
if that happens then there is an
unlimited amount of money that they can
actually
receive in that type of case and i think
they do have some constitutional claims
here some due process claims where they
can make and and make some damages here
it's interesting of course we'll follow
that case if that civil case does in
fact come up but right now these men are
exonerated one posthumously one still
alive like you said taylor good day for
all when we come back the latest in a
long list of lawsuits against actors and
producers of the ill-fated movie rust
right gloria allred says alec baldwin
was playing a game of russian roulette
at the time of the deadly shooting on
the movie sets all that and more after
the break
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
famed attorney gloria allred announces
another lawsuit against actor alec
baldwin accusing him of playing russian
roulette on the film set of rust
as law on crime daily first reported
last month alec baldwin was rehearsing
on the set when he fired a gun loaded
with a live round cinematographer helena
hutchins was shot and killed and
director joel souza was injured the
movie's script supervisor mamie mitchell
is the latest to file a lawsuit against
the actors and producers claiming
emotional distress and deliberate
infliction of harm mitchell was the
first one to call 9-1-1 after the
shooting in a press conference on
wednesday already announced she would
represent mitchell and said baldwin
ignored safety protocols and played
russian roulette by firing the gun
without checking it or having an armor
checker
taylor mitchell was a witness to the
tragic death she did not physically get
harmed how does it claim like this work
yeah you know with all deference to
gloria allred and her very long and
successful career only she could do this
right she could take this tragedy
because that's what it is and hijack it
uh for monetary gain for a party that
literally had nothing to do with the
incident i understand she was present i
understand she called 9-1-1 she wasn't
injured she wasn't one of the two
parties who unfortunately lost their
life or was you know seriously injured
it was just someone who was essentially
watching and if that's what we're doing
now if we are taking people who just
happen to be around when bad things
happen and suing uh for great big deal
you know alec baldwin's huge pocket if
that's what we're doing well there's no
big surprise that there are thousands
and thousands of jokes at lawyers
expenses
i hear the jokes on our expenses
definitely terry there are now over a
hundred laws that have been filed in
connection with this one event do you
think this could amount to a class
action
you know brian it could if there are
dozens and dozens of people who are
suing the class action would have to be
certified and it would have to be
clearly defined and you'd have to have
the same harm and you'd have to have the
same defendant so it's really going to
be a question of whether or not the same
laws the same facts and i think here we
do have that if these individuals are
all harmed in the same way and it really
will save on resources as far as
multiple trials might be concerned you
want to make sure that the state is
saving resources and not having multiple
lawsuits for something that really could
all be tried together so we'll see what
happens but if the numbers continue to
rise i think that is something that
they're going to have to consider to
keep the expenses down hey maybe we'll
see that gloria allred is representing
this class action suit as taylor i may
have been suggesting about her picking
up more cases well thank you both and
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you